[Musique]
à bord de cette bouée viola et ses
enfants se font gentiment chahuté
s'ils peuvent profiter de cette
attraction c'est grâce au secours
populaire
car les vacances pour cette famille
c'est souvent dans sa commune de
résidence
on part rarement à chaque fois qu'on
peut aller c'est tout le pas à les voir
soit de la famille mais les billets de
train ou d'avion c'est trop trop trop
cher et bien on reste mais soit ils
viennent mais on peut ne jamais partir
en vacances et pour viola c'est
l'occasion de profiter d'un bon moment
en famille compte en sorte en sortant
semble hélas et c'est bien on s'amuse
tout la famille c'est bien
dans ce célèbre parc de dompierre sur
besbre près de 10000 visiteurs viennent
profiter des manèges et du parc
animalier et par pillé dans cette foule
près de 600 familles venues de six
départements de bourgogne franche comté
peuvent s'octroyer une journée de
détente
[Musique]
nous personnellement financièrement ce
n'est pas possible on a quand même deux
enfants deux petits travail et
bénéficient du secours populaire
bah c'est important on en a besoin
c
surtout pour les sorties pour faire
plaisir aux enfants et passer une bonne
journée tout en famille quoi voilà déjà
40 ans que cette journée des oubliés des
vacances est organisée on s'est aperçu
que des familles où les enfants qui sont
pas partis en vacances après le 15 ou ne
partirons pas je ne sais pas beaucoup
mais les enfants des choses raconté en
rentrant de vacances
une initiative qui aura permis aux
nombreuses familles bénéficiaires de
garder des souvenirs inoubliables